adjusting with talked about how this
amplification and the approximate degree
of constant depth circuits thanks for
the introduction so this is joint work
with mark Bunn who's a graduate student
at Harvard I'll actually be describing
results from two papers we've had in the
last year and it's the second paper
which I'll get to in the latter part of
the talk that yields the title so I'll
start with some standard notation so
throughout this talk f will denote a
boolean function mapping minus 1 1 to
the n 2 minus 1 1 and will associate
minus 1 with logical true and plus 1
with logical false so for example the n
function will evaluate 2-1 if all of its
inputs are equal to minus 1 and will
evaluate to plus 1 otherwise so this
talk will be about a certain measure of
the complexity of a boolean function
known as approximate degree so this
quantity is defined as follows so a real
polynomial P is said to epsilon
approximate a boolean function f if P of
X minus f of X is bounded in absolute
value by epsilon for all points X in the
boolean hypercube so this is a
worst-case notion of approximation he
has to be accurate a good approximation
for F at every single point in the
boolean hypercube now the epsilon
approximate degree of f denoted as
follows right here is the minimum degree
needed to epsilon approximate F and if
we don't actually specify epsilon then
by convention we take epsilon equal to
one-third and we just refer to the
approximate degree of f so we could
actually replace one-third with any
constant strictly less than one and it
wouldn't change the theory in any way
it's chosen by convention so hopefully
you saw that definition and you
immediately recognize that this was a
very natural measure of the complexity
of a boolean function and worthy of
study but if you disagree with that
there are some other reasons to care
about it as well for example upper
bounds on approximate degree immediately
yield efficient learning algorithms and
in fact underlie many of the fastest
known learning algorithms in a wide
variety of scenarios and at a high level
the more stringent or challenging the
learning environment the tighter we need
the approximations to be so in some
learning scenarios epsilon the error
parameter can be arbitrarily close to
one and then others more challenging
scenarios we need epsilon to be a
constant strictly less than one other
applications are of lower bounds on
approximate degree are as follows
lower bounds on approximate degree
immediately you lower bounds on quantum
query complexity communication
complexity and circuit complexity draw
your attention in particular to the
circuit complexity bullet point you'll
notice that a lot of these references
are only a few years old so dual
formulations of approximate degree that
we're going to see at length in this
talk have in the last several years been
used to resolve several long-standing
open questions and communication
complexity and we'll see one or two of
these applications in the talk we also
won't get to some okay so now that you
care about approximate degree I want to
quickly run through a relatively simple
example just to familiarize ourselves
with the concept I'll explain or I'll
characterize the approximate degree of
the end function which has been known
now for 20 years since the seminal work
of nissan and sega d on so the
approximate degree of the end function
is root n and the upper bound makes use
of the chebyshev polynomials so this is
a extremel and it's an extremely useful
extremel family of polynomials and let
me motivate why they come up in this
setting as follows so Markos inequality
from approximation theory on not to be
confused with Marcos inequality from
probability theory says the following so
let G be a univariate polynomial of
degree at most D and assume that at all
points in the unit interval T the
absolute value of G is bounded by one so
G is bounded of the unit interval
nockels inequality states that the
derivative at G at all points in the
unit interval is itself bounded by at
most the square of the degree and in
fact the chebyshev polynomials are
extract are exactly extremel for marcos
inequality so I've drawn here the
chebyshev polynomial of degree 16 and
what you can see is that on you know it
has these very large derivatives this
big jump right at the end points of the
unit interval and in the interior of the
interval it's sort of oscillating as
quickly as I can around zero and Marcus
inequality says that no degree sixty
polynomial can have a bigger jump if it
stays bounded in the unit interval a
bigger derivative so why is this useful
for approximating the end function so by
shifting and scaling on this chebyshev
polynomial we can achieve a polynomial
that looks like this so what I've done
is I've shifted the polynomial so that
it has a big jump right around minus one
so at the input minus one it takes value
rate about minus one and then it jumps
very quickly up to +1 and it sort of
hovers around there for the rest of the
unit interval and intuitively this is
what kind of what we want to approximate
the end function because the end
function evaluates 2-1 on a single input
the input a maximal Hamming weight and
evaluates the +1 everywhere else and in
fact if we apply this univariate
polynomial which I'll call queue to the
Hamming weight of an n-dimensional you
know boolean input this will in fact be
an approximation to the end function and
we only need the green route n because
we need this derivative to the N roughly
proportional to N and we can do that
with chebyshev polynomials of degree
rudin so that's why the root end comes
in the upper bound let's at a high level
talk about the lower bound argument of
nissan and sega d so this argument uses
a technique called symmetrization on and
this technique works as follows so
suppose we had an N variant
approximation to the n function call it
P what symmetrization does is it turns
this n very polynomial into a universe
polynomial I'll call it P sim and argues
that the univariate polynomial has to
look like this so this is exactly the
picture we had on the previous slide so
I'll hide the details of how we exactly
go from P to P sim but we argued that it
has to look like this and moreover we
argue that this map is non sorry degree
non-increasing that is the degree of
peace in is at most a degree of P so
therefore if P sim had high degree so
those p as well and marcos inequality
says that because peace in has a large
jump right here and stays bounded in the
whole unit interval that PC must have
large degree must have degree at least
root N and therefore P does as well and
that's the lower bound okay so that's a
scimitar ization was the primary
technique we had for proving approximate
degree lower bounds for many years on
and this talk will focus on techniques
for going beyond symmetrization so
intuitively cemeteries ation while very
powerful has its limitations it appears
to be a lossy technique so in turning an
n variate polynomial p into a univariate
polynomial p sim we have to throw away a
lot of information about P right we're
taking this very high dimensional object
this n very polynomial and turn it into
turning it into a univariate one we we
have to be throwing away some
information so in the case of symmetric
functions we still have enough
information around to prove tight lower
bounds but for non symmetric functions
we really seem to run into a be
here and there was a long-standing while
relatively long standing on challenge
problem to resolve the approximate
degree of a function known as the
two-level or ends tree so this was a
challenge problem because it was the
simplest function that symmetry zation
seemed to break down for so in the or
entry it's the function is simply a read
once dnf so that is it's a depth to
boolean circuit and for simplicity
Allison its balance so every single gate
in the circuit has fan in root N and for
notational convenience I'll call the
input to the I end gate X sub I so each
X sub I has a brute and variables within
X sub I and there are root n of the X of
ice any questions about this function ok
so here's a brief history of progress on
resolving the approximate degree of this
function so in 2003 hoyer warrior moscow
and the wolf proved an upper bound of
root n on now progress on lower bounds
was incremental spanning many years so
nice on and sega DS fundamental result
about the end function immediately
yields a lower bound of n to the
one-fourth the reason being that if you
look at just a single end gate within
this function that itself has
approximate degree at least end of the
one-fourth now progress proceeded sort
of in fits and jumps in 2008 Aronson
reposed the question during a fox
tutorial again because the problems seem
to capture the limitations of symmetry
zation and earlier this year mark and I
approved a matching lower bound at end
of the one-half and sure stove around
the same time independently achieved the
same result so I'll start by telling you
how we achieve this result so the
high-level technique that we use is to
use a linear programming formulation of
approximate degree and we certainly did
not introduce this technique it has been
used in several prior works dating back
several years so this technique works as
follows so we can ask fix a boolean
function f what is the best error
achievable by any degree D approximation
to F so the answer to this question is
actually the value of a linear program
so the limit the variables in this LP
are the era parameter epsilon and the
coefficients of our degree D polynomial
P and the program simply says minimize
the error parameter epsilon subject to
the constraints that P actually be an
epsilon approximation for F so this is
not a linear program in standard form
but standard
manipulations can turn it into one and
you can take the dual of this LP and
don't stare too hard it is quite yet but
I've written the dual up here and the
point is that if you exhibit a good
solution to the duo LP that gives a
lower bound on the value of the primal
which says that any degree D
approximation to F has to have high
error so giving good duel solutions to
the duo LP is equivalent to proving
approximate degree lower bounds so
that's the the approach that we take and
let's look at this duel in more detail
so strong duality says that I should I
guess I'll mention on this technique is
completely lossless in the sense that
strong duality says that whatever the
right answer is whatever the approximate
degree of f is there is a dual witness
that will exhibit it so all we have to
do is construct it we haven't thrown
away the game at the start okay so what
does a duel witness look like so the
witness is just a function on on the
boolean hypercube it's real valued and
I'm going to refer to it as a dual
polynomial for reasons that will
hopefully become clear so the first
property that a dual witness has to
satisfy is its correlation with F must
be at least epsilon so actually the
correlation of the dual polynomial with
F is the objective value of the dual so
you need that to be larger than epsilon
to prove an epsilon approximate degree
lower bound that says that any degree D
polynomial has to have error at least
epsilon the first constraint of the
dough LP says that the l1 norm of side
the dual polynomial has to be exactly
one that's just a normalization
constraints so actually ignore it
through the whole talk and just assume
that all of our dual polynomials are
normalized to have l1 norm one on the
final set of constraints says that ass I
has to have exactly zero correlation
with every polynomial of degree at most
D equivalently sigh all of the low
degree Fourier coefficients of psy have
to be zero so if you write sigh out as a
polynomial it has no low degree terms so
I'll refer to this as having pure high
degree D so intuitively what's I is it's
capturing it the part of F that is of
pure high degree that is completely
missed by low degree polynomials so if
this part of F is significant in the
sense that is well correlated with F
then any degree D approximation has to
have large error and this this duel
formulation has proved essential in
several prior works and our goal now is
to construct an explicit dual polynomial
for the or entry um so a very natural
approach this problem is the following
so by Nissan and Sega d is fundamental
result we know that the approximate
degree of or an end on end of the
one-half variables is n to the
one-fourth for each of them so there is
a dual polynomial for each of these
functions exhibiting this fact so I'm
going to call these sigh out in sight in
ok so the question is like our goal is
to get a dual polynomial for the block
compose function or composed with end
the question is can we combine sigh out
in sigh in to get a dual polynomial for
this block compose function um so here's
a first attempt at doing this and it
won't work but it will sort of fail in a
instructive way so the primal function
we're trying to argue about is the block
composition of or with end so it's very
natural to just block compose dual
witnesses see what happens so we need to
prove two things if this is going to be
a good duel witness we need to show that
it has pure high degree at least n to
the one half and we need to show that is
good correlation with the or entry on so
it actually does have the pure high
degree that we want and this is really a
trivial fact I'll see if I can sketch it
right now all it's saying is that if you
take a polynomial with no low degree
terms and you black compose it with
another polynomial with no low degree
terms and you just expand everything out
and collect everything then the degree
of the resulting terms will blow up
multiplicatively so a little more
concretely if one of the terms for sy
out let's say the only term was the
product of two variables and similarly
for sy n when you just block compose
them then each variable inside out turns
into two variables from the inner
polynomial and same with the other
variable appearing inside out and what
you get is the product of four variables
ok so anyway this is a straw man anyway
so if that's a new quite make sense
that's ok the important point here is
it's actually the correlation analysis
that doesn't work and intuitively the
correlation analysis fails for the
following reason so we have control over
the values that sigh out takes on
boolean inputs right we know sigh out by
being a dual witness for the
or function has good correlation with or
on boolean inputs but we're not feeding
boolean inputs into sci out here we're
feeding real values into sci out because
sine is a real valued function okay so
we have no control over the combine two
witnesses values and in fact this this
fails badly um so what do we do so we
actually did not introduce what we do
this was introduced in prior work by
sure student Lee and what we do is
essentially the simplest thing you could
want to do if you want to force boolean
values to be fed into SIA okay what we
do is we feed the sign of scien into SIA
now we still need to take into account
the magnitude of scien in some way so we
do that in the simplest way possible we
simply multiply by all of the magnitude
sort of outside the composition ok now
it's not clear at all that this composed
polynomial this combined the witness
satisfies either the conditions we
needed to either pure high degree dis or
good correlation with or end but it
turns out it does satisfy both so the
first condition was actually established
in prior work that introduced this
combining technique and it's the high
correlation analysis that was the
contribution of the new work so even
though sure stove analyzed the pure high
degree of the combos the witness i want
to give some intuition for why this fact
holds so i'll do that very quickly so
for intuition consider a sigh out that
takes three inputs and ignores the the
third input just outputs the product of
the first two so this has pure high
degree too alright so then if you just
look at what this equation for the
combined do witness what you get is um
right so you replace Y one with sine of
X 1 sine of scien of X 1 and similarly
for y 2 so you get assigned term for
each of the variables actually appearing
inside out and then you get the
magnitudes outside the composition ok
and now for each of the variables that
do have assigned to each of the blocks
that do have a sine term we can combine
it with their magnitudes to just gets I
in back out so what we have here is we
have a product of several whatever the
pure haida greenness of sight out is we
get that many copies of sy n and then
get a whole bunch of magnitudes that we
don't have any information about and we
just essentially ignore okay these don't
hurt us are pure high degree in us
because we're over there over disjoint
variables than the other blocks but they
don't help us either the point is that
if you multiply a whole bunch of
polynomials each with no low degree
terms then once again if you collect
terms the pure Heidi greenness behaves
multiplicatively so maybe maybe this
isn't coming across completely but is
the high level picture roughly clear are
there any questions about this right so
what you the way you should think of it
is um right so let's imagine that this
was just you know the product of you
know several variables from the first
block this is the product of several
variables from the second block and this
is just something involving variables
from the third lock you know this
something might have degree one it might
have degree a million it doesn't matter
it so it's just different variables it's
still the case that one you just write
out like the the furry a expression of
this thing everything with a nonzero
coefficient will involve a lot of
variables from the first two blocks
that's what's happening any other
questions okay so let's go to the
correlation analysis where I'm going to
wave my hands even more on so the idea
here is the following what we want to do
is we want to show that the combined
bill witness has good correlation with
the composed target function and the way
we do that is we show that this
correlation is approximately equivalent
to the correlation of the outer dual
witness with the outer target function
or and the intuition for why this
approximate equality should hold is the
following so we are feeding a sign of sy
in of all of the blocks into the outer
the witness right and the point is that
sy n is correlated with the inner
function right that was one of the
properties that any dual witness for the
inner function had to satisfy as a
result a sign of scien is a decent
predictor for the inner function ok so
normally if you look at like an average
case input to the inner function right
sinus I in will actually agree exactly
what the inner function but there are
errors so all we need to do is we need
to show
the areas don't build up in some sense
and to make this intuition a little more
precise I'll point out that if if Sian
was actually perfectly correlated with
the inner function then this approximate
equality would hold with exact equality
so we're really just trying to show that
errors don't build up in some sense okay
so that's the main point that I wanted
to get across now I'm going to try to
convey the details but it's going to be
a little more challenging so again our
goal is to show that the correlation of
the combined dual witness with the
combined function is approximately equal
to the correlation of the outer the
witness with the outer function and the
analysis proceeds for in two cases so
let's denote the vector of values were
actually feeding into the outer dual
witness by why okay so the first case
considers a why that is not equal to the
all false factor so that is we're
actually feeding some coordinate some
true coordinate into the outer dual
witness now the point is that we only
need to trust this single true
coordinate we only need to make sure
that coordinate is error-free to force
the value of the combined function to
evaluate to true actually evaluate to
chew on this input what's happening here
is that the or function evaluates to
true if even a single input is set to
true so if the outer dual witness thinks
one of its inputs is true all you have
to do is believe that single input and
and then you know the outer go witness
is really sort of believing the right
thing that's the intuition for what's
happening so formally we're using the
fact that the certificate complexity of
or on one of these inputs is one all
right so errors do not build up there on
the other cases to consider y equal to
the all false vector so here we're
really in trouble because we really need
to trust that all of these coordinates
are error-free all right if even a
single of these things that the Allard
witness believes is false is actually
true then you change the value of or and
you're really in trouble so fortunately
the interval witness has a special one
sided arrow property that I recognize
it's coming out of nowhere right now
I'll explain in a minute but this
interval witness satisfies the following
property if sign of the interval witness
evaluated of any input is 1 then in fact
the end function evaluated on that same
input is guaranteed to equal one there
is no error in this case and and we're
done that completes the correlation
analysis so in
Murray and again I will explain why this
one sided arrow property holds in just a
minute in summary the correlation
analysis proceeds in two cases so in the
first case we're feeding at least one
true one true coordinate into the outer
the witness and aerith did not go to up
because we only needed to trust that
single true value in the second case all
of the values we fed into were false we
need to trust all of them but we could
because of this one sided arrow property
any questions about that much of the
proof okay so let's talk about this one
sided arrow property um all right so I
need to introduce a newish variance of
approximate degree which we call
one-sided approximate degree so a real
polynomial p is said to be a one-sided
epsilon approximation for a boolean
function f if the following two
conditions are satisfied so for inputs
in F inverse of one we insist that the
approximation be a true epsilon
approximation all right it has error at
most one sr at most epsilon relative to
f but for inputs in f inverse of minus
one we only require a threshold
condition on p we only require that p be
smaller than minus 1 okay so this is
actually the one-sided approximate
degree of any boolean function is always
at most the approximate degree but it
could be much smaller um so similarly to
approximate degree we let the one-sided
approximate degree 2 error epsilon be
the minimum degree of a one-sided
epsilon approximation and if we don't
specify epsilon just as soon it's one
third so where did this come from ah so
if you write the natural lunar program
capturing one-sided approximate degree
and you take its dual what you get out
is exactly the approximate degree duel
with an extra set of constraints these
extra set of constraints says that the
dual witness has to be non-positive on
all inputs and f inverse of minus one so
put another way if this duel witness
outputs something positive then you know
that the input must be in F inverse of
one that's exactly the property we
needed for the proof to go through all
right so I've completely you know sort
of convinced you that or proof holds as
long as I can argue that the approximate
degree of the end function is root n
that is the same as its approximate
degree so let me explain an intuitive
level why this should be the case
um so if we well in the case of
approximate degree I argued that the
lower bound held because we could take
any approximate approximating polynomial
for the end function and symmetrized it
into a polynomial that look like this so
would have a big jump right around minus
one and then it would stay bounded for
the rest of the Union interval now if we
replace the approximate condition with a
threshold condition on the input you
know F inverse of minus one all we do is
make the jump bigger and Marcos and
equality still applies and that's it so
that's the intuitive reason why the one
side approximate degree is high it's
actually even easier to see we have
explicit dual witnesses for the end
function and they have one sided error
but this is the reason that is maybe
more you know intuitive to people who
are a little bit familiar with
approximate degree okay so that
completes the first part of the talk any
any questions at this point ok so I'll
get to the hardness amplification um for
constant depth circuits in particular so
our goal here is the following suppose
we are given a quote-unquote simple
boolean function f that is hard to
approximate to low error by degree
polynomials can we turn F into a still
simple function capital F that is hard
to approximate even to high error so
we're asking can we somehow take little
f and turn it into a much harder
function that's still simple in some way
and the answer we give is yes in the
following quantitative sense so let F be
any function with high up one-sided
approximate degree so one side
approximate degree at least d and
consider the or of T destroyed copies of
F okay then the one-sided approximate
degree of this combined function is also
at least d but this is holds even if we
allow the error to be exponentially
close to 1 so capital F is much harder
to approximate and a very important
point here is that if F was a constant
depth circuit then so is capital with ok
so let's just jump into the proof of
this theorem so we've already done a lot
of the conceptual work in sort of
explaining how the proof will go so just
like before we're going to take a dual
witness for the inner function which in
this case is an arbitrary function f
with high one-sided approximate degree
and we're going to you know let this
duel witness actually witness the
I one-sided approximate degree the inner
function we're going to use a very
different outer duel witness in this
case so this outer duel witness will
evaluate to one half on the all false
input minus one half on the Altru input
and it will just ignore everyone else
just evaluate to 0 and we're going to
combine these dual witnesses exactly as
before to obtain a dual witness for the
compose function capital F and we just
have to verify that this combined the
witness has pure high degree at least D
and correlation at least 1-2 to the
minus T with capital F so let's do that
let's start with the pure high degree
calculation which is we've already
essentially done so notice that ass I
out is balanced so that is it has
expected value zero right it took value
of one half on a single input to value
minus one half on another and ignored
everything else so it's a balance
function and that's just another way of
saying it has pure high degree one okay
so we already argued that when we
combine dual witnesses in the way of the
manner of sure stove and Lee then the
pure high degree Gnaeus grows
multiplicatively so in this case we get
out 1 times D which is just d so that
was easy so the meat of the analysis is
in the correlation analysis and yeah let
me try to give the intuition for this
again so we're going to try to do the
same thing we're going to try to show
that the combined dual witness its
correlation with F is roughly equal to
the outer duel witnesses correlation
with or now the this approximate
equality has to hold like very tightly
right the gap has to be at most 2 to the
minus T um note that the outer the
witness actually had perfect correlation
with or so this if we prove this we
actually do get the desired 1-2 to the
minus T correlation so the analysis once
again proceeds in two cases based on
what we're feeding into the outer dual
witness here it's naturally only two
cases because the outer duel witness
only pays attention to two vectors
alright so the first case is the Altru
input we're feeding the Altru input into
the outer duel witness um so in this
case if even a single coordinate of this
vector Y is error-free then we're happy
that is the or function evaluates to
what to true if even a single one of its
inputs is true and here we're feeding in
a whole bunch of truths all
them are true so we only have to trust
one of them all right now each
coordinate we're feeding in makes an
error with probability only one half
because the interval witness is well
correlated with F and in fact these
errors happen independently all right
there's actually a product distribution
at play i'm sort of hand waving those
details because this is a product so
these errors happen independently and
therefore all of these are an error with
probability only 2 to the minus t
sensors to you then okay so that case is
done and and the other case we already
handled in the other case we're feeding
in the all false vector in this case we
have to trust all of these coordinates
but we can because we assume that the
inner door witness is one-sided error
that's acrylic any questions about this
hand wavy proof okay um all right so our
ultimate goal is to apply or hardness
amplification techniques to functions in
ac0 functions computed by constant depth
circuits in order to get very hard
functions that are still in ac0 so to do
this we need to prove a good one sided
approximate degree lower bound for AC 0
now I already argued that the n function
had one side approximate degree root N
and that's an AC 0 so that's a start can
we do better so we can and what we use
is called the element distinctness
function so the definition of this
function isn't so important we use it as
a black box but let me try to say what
it is so it interprets its n bit input
as a sequence of numbers let's say n
over log n numbers each from a range of
size roughly n and it outputs true if
and only if all of those numbers are
distinct that's what the function does
so aronson and she showed in 2004 on
early steps the journal version i think
that the approximate degree of this
function is at least roughly end of the
two thirds and in fact this is a tight
lower bound for this function um so
they're proof actually used a very
intricate symmetrization argument it's a
remarkable argument and this is the
best-known lower bound on the
approximate degree of an AC 0 function
so we show that in fact the one-sided
approximate degree of this function is
roughly end of the two thirds and our
proof proceeds as follows so we use
aronson she's lower bound as a black box
and what we do is we show how to take
any dual witness to the approximate
degree of the element distance function
and
into a dual witness with one-sided error
generically so it's interesting Aronson
she's proof is really remarkable and it
argues only about the primal right is
actually using symmetrization and
arguing about polynomial approximations
and are sort of extension or
strengthening of their proof only uses
the Dual View and uses their their
result as a black box I actually don't
know how to prove this lower bound via
the primal view so that would be I would
be interested to see one but anyway I'm
on the pre no so all we're looking for
here is so we prove the theorem on the
previous slide that amplifies hardness
and we're looking for a function to
amplify the hardness of here yes so any
questions about the one-sided
approximate degree lower bound for
element 2 stickiness ok um so by
combining our hardest amplification
result with our one-sided approximate
degree lower bound for element
distinctness we achieve the following
theorem so the parameters of this
theorem um we actually achieve sort of
smooth trade-offs between the error and
the degree lower bounds that we get out
but I'm picking a particular point on
the trade-off curve that is most
important for applications so what we
get is a function in AC 0 such that it's
one-sided approximate degree is n to the
two fifths or so even if you allow error
1 minus 2 to the minus end of the tube
fits that's what comes out when you
combine the horniest amplification
result with the element to sting nets
lower bound on elemental Cygnus is
computed by a depth to CNF so this or of
a bunch of copies of element to sickness
is computed by depth three circuit um
right so let's talk about applications
so now I have to talk about discrepancy
I think Shekhar introduced it in the
first taco today the definition is not
so important but I guess in the sentence
on discrepancy captures the correlation
of F with constant cost communication
protocols also known as combinatorial
rectangles on but here's the important
point on low discrepancy of a function
implies that the function has high
communication complexity
in nearly every communication model it
also is a central quantity and learning
theory and circuit complexity and it was
open for many years to prove an
exponential exponentially small
discrepancy lower bound for AC 0 and
that was resolved in 2007 and 2008 by
sure stove and Berman very shaken and
the wolf and we use sure stoves
techniques so in short stoves 2008 paper
on the pattern makers method he showed
how to take any function with high
approximate degree and turn it into a
related function with X with low
discrepancy and the transformation
preserves membership in ac0 right it
added lines up adding one extra layer to
the circuit and the actual bound on
discrepancy that he gets out ignoring
some terms that are not consequential
for us is the maximum of 1 over w & 2 to
the minus d we're here 1 over w is the
distance of the error parameter from 1
and d is the degree of the lower bound
on so the lower bound or it's an upper
bound on discrepancy is strongest when
one over w equals 2 to the minus d and
that's exactly the parameter settings
that i had set in the previous corollary
so what we get out is we get an AC 0
function f computed by a depth for
circuit because this transformation add
an extra layer with discrepancy 2 to the
minus end of the two fits all right and
this improves over the previous lower
balance of sure stove burman very shaken
and the wolf which was to to the end of
the one third we also get a number of
immediate corollaries from this result
for example we get a function in ac0
that is not computed by majority of
threshold circuits of size 2 to the end
of the teuthis we get a new threshold
weight lower bound for AC 0 I'm not
going to go into details about this um I
guess I have time to cover the final
result that I didn't think I would get
to which is back to our entries so
earlier in the talk we resolved the
approximate degree of the or entry of
depth to but it remains open to resolve
or we nearly we will nearly resolve it
on this slide the approximate degree of
or entries of
higher depth so let's let or end d comma
n denote the or entry of depth D so this
is a read once a boolean circuit let's
assume that it's regular so all gates
have been in n to the 1 over d and let's
stick an or gate at the top so all this
is is a regular read once depth D
circuit that's it sure every even like
it's not bound in depth hmm just
automating the end or three into the
usual maybe it's not so too so I
certainly know that the quantum query
complexity had already been resolved ya
know so not necessarily right so
approximate degree lower bounds panel
career complexity but they're not
necessarily equivalent so to the best of
my knowledge the best previous lower
bound for depth 3 or greater was n to
the one-fourth plus 1 over 2 D and you
actually only get the one over to D if
you use our depth to lower bound okay so
anyways for dep 3 or greater we prove
the following lower bound so we almost
resolve it so we get a lower down of end
of the one half modulo some logarithmic
terms and this matches an upper bound of
n to the one-half that follows from a
recent result of sure stuff about making
polynomials for busting noise so you can
essentially compose their approximations
um okay so let me sketch at a very high
level how we prove the lower bound so
and I'm going to look at the case only d
equals 3 um so a first attempt that's
very natural is to view the or entry of
dep 3 as just war composed with the end
or tree of depth to right so we can let
us I out denote a dual polynomial
witnessing the high approximate degree
of the or function and we can let's I in
denote a dual polynomial for the end or
jury of depth to that we essentially
constructed at the start of the talk
that was for the or
Depa too but it's it's a trivial
modification and then we can try to
combine the dual witnesses exactly as
before in the manner of sure Stephen Lee
and we just have to argue that this
thing would have pure high degree n to
the one half and good correlation with
the target function now the pure high
degree calculation goes through just as
before but the correlation calculation
is again the sticking point the problem
is that the dual witness we had for
depth to did not have one sided error
alright so the dual witness for depth to
sort of took an inner function with
one-sided error use that to argue high
correlation of the composed of witness
but did not preserve one-sided error so
this does not work instead what we do is
we use a different dual polynomial for
the inner function on four to get this
polynomial we use hardest amplification
to achieve the following so while our
inner duel witness will have error on
both sides the error from the wrong side
will be very small and that's actually
all we need for the correlation analysis
to go through you know hand waving all
the way so the hardness amplification
step loses us a factor of root log n in
the degree we needed to kind of use some
of the fannin from the top gate sins in
the circuit to do harness amplification
rather than degree amplification but
it's only it's only a logarithmic factor
so that's what's going on there okay so
in my last three minutes I guess any any
questions about that final result ok so
in my last three minutes I want to talk
about some very exciting work bye-bye
sure stove that is hot off the press
maybe not I don't even think it's off
the press yet he did give us permission
to mention these results during this
talk on so these results are in
threshold degree on so this is defined
as follows on so let F be a boolean
function a polynomial P sign represents
F if the sign of P at all inputs X
bullying inputs equals f of X so the
threshold degree of f is the minimum
degree of a polynomial P that sign
represents F so this is equivalent to
the approximate degree as the error
parameter epsilon approaches one ok so
in 1968 and seminal work Minsky and
Papert proved an end of the one-third
lower bound on the threshold degree of a
specific dnf and that's been a very
influential and important result
on in learning theory and elsewhere and
it's been open ever since to prove a
lower bound of end of the one-third plus
Delta for any Delta strictly greater
than zero for any function in ac0 the
only progress we've seen in 45 years is
a poly logarithmic improvement by
O'Donnell answer video from 2003 so we
conjectured in in our hardness
amplification paper that this function
you know or compose with element
distinctness that we use for our
discrepancy down in fact had threshold
degree into the two fifths which would
have been in fact is the first
polynomial improvement over min skin
pampered so sasha has proved our
conjecture and he has actually proved
something much stronger or stronger he
exhibits a depth k circuit of polynomial
size with threshold degree n to the K
minus 1 over 2 K minus 1 so as K grows
for any constant K this is always some
constant strictly less than one-half but
it's of getting closer and closer to one
half as K gross on so in fact the proof
of our conjecture sure stones proof is
roughly it's a refinement of our
techniques and it's only about a page
however this this stronger result is is
much more technically involved with with
several imports and new idea so we're
very excited to learn about this and I
wanted to close by mentioning that so
that's all I have thank you very much
um it's it's rude n at least for
constant e super custody I'm not just so
right so I know there is a lower bound I
believe this is completely known that
there's so there's a a lower bound of
root n follows for that by reduction
from parody you can actually encode
parody and rude and variables in that
and I'm pretty sure that's tight but I
have to think about why it's tight
actually it's the end so you said we are
composing there and with all meals that
I approximate the hood normal service so
just where bottom if you compose Andrew
the end no well no well no it will not
so I thought about this a lot there's a
conjecture that on right in general for
any harm say G and F that are boolean
there's a conjecture that the
approximate degree of the block
composition of G with after is greater
than or equal to the approximate degree
of G times the approximate degree of f
you know modulo some constant factors
right so what what shirts to showed that
actually gives the upper bound of root n
for arbitrary constant depth is a
converse to this so he made polynomials
robust to noise in a way that lets you
combine their approximations now this
question is still open on and you can
think of our result for and the Oratory
is just showing like another case
special case where this conjecture is
true and my intuition is the following
so a function like end is one of the few
cases that I have we're like our
techniques don't look like clearly break
down and yet the conjecture is true
anyway so if you had a way to somehow
unify the fact that and has a proximate
degree route add and the fact that the
it you know the end or tree works then
you might resolve
this conjecture but for me for the end
the work to such as that does that hold
for arbitrary depths not even okay so
there's one is it believed that there is
a pound of n 2 1 minus Delta for all ace
20 or something um so I'm not sure that
there's any consensus on that that's
that's my belief my belief is that the
right answer is at least n to the 1
minus Delta for any constant Delta but
i'm not sure if there's a consensus on
what the right answer is
it does not
I mean I mean it right so um I'm not
sure I should be on record as
speculating on this but uh maybe I will
I guess I will so um I'll make the
following conjecture so this is a very
yeah I don't know this is pure
speculation so let F be any function
with one sided approximate degree d
alright so i might conjecture that if
you let sort of nf2 note the negation of
f and you block compose NF say k times i
might conjecture that this as you as K
increases the threshold degree of this
function is approaching the one-sided
approximate degree of that right so so
so so block composition wants we'll just
the NF composed with itself and at times
and I mean this to be regular so you
know like root n here and each of these
have fan in root n so and now I'm saying
do it k times block composing k times
and it's you know it's that this is my
ridiculous speculation right ok so the
conjectures the following so suppose a
little F has one sided approximate too
greedy ok um the conjecture is low cut
the negation of F and this has just done
on to ensure that right like or composed
with or does not have high threshold
degree but or compose with n does and
that's just to get this kind of
alternation in there the negation of F
now so the K equals to version of my
conjecture would be that the threshold
degree of the NF composed with itself
like root and copies of itself each of
fan and root n that would be like
composing black composing it once and if
you do it again you would you know
just keep doing this and as you keep
doing this um I think it's conceivable
that the threshold degree is approaching
the one-sided approximate degree of the
original function right so what we write
so the the approximate degree of a c0 is
still wide open as well right and there
are some candidates for functions right
the quantum query conductive ac0 is
known to be n over log n that's a result
of beam and I believe his student and
however no download down for the
approximate degree better than any of
the two thirds is known and that's you
know an important question in mono was
not to my knowledge well i'm actually
not familiar with the function but on
you know it right you want to find that
with both sure so there is there is um
right right so there's so so so there's
a on candidate function so the function
we know that is quantum query complexity
and over log n okay which is um it's the
search activity function okay and you
know it's a natural conjecture that this
function in fact has you know n over log
and approximate degree and Aronson
showed in a paper where he proved the
generalized lineal nissan conjecture
false that this function has like very
high block sensitivity in like an
average case sense so it satisfies
properties such as you know the ones
you're mentioning and is a very natural
candidate for such a lower bound
thousands of teen beat indicates the to
substitute a no so 2013 a was when
Trista independently resolved the
approximate degree of the two-level
and/or tree that was that was short of
13 a hey that's a good way